اكشن
لقد كان لدينا انتخابات يوم امس وكان يوما
جيدا ده الديمقراطيه واعتقد انه كان يوما
جيدا للولايات المتحده الامريكيه امتحنت
الديمقراطيه للولايات المتحده للسنوات
الماضيه ولكن الشعب الامريكي تحدث واثبت
ان الديمقراطيه هي هوياتنا الولايات شهدت
مشاركه بمعدلات قياسيه
والعاملين في مراكز الاختراع والمسؤولين
على الانتخابات وهم في صلب هذه العمليه
الدواء الواجب باكمل وجه من دون اي تدخل
بعملهم وهذا الشهاده
مع ان همم الصحافه توقعت مادا احمر او
موجه حمراء كبيره هذه الموجه لم تحصل
وطبعا تقولون ان لدي تفاؤل ولكن انا على
اي حال شعرت اننا سوف نبلي بلاء حسنا في
كل العمليه هناك بعض الخساره التي مرينا
بها ولكن
الديمقراطيون كان
لديهم ليله جيده وخسرنا بعض
المقاعد وكان لدينا افضل انتخابات بنستطيع
الحكام منذ العام 86 وايضا
الناخبونه تحدثوا بشكل واضح حول المخاوف
التي لديهام ارتفاع الاسعار و ضروره كبح
التضخم هذه المخاوف بالاضافه الى الجريمه
والسلامه العامه وارسل الشعب رساله واضحه
لضروره حمايه الديمقراطيه والحق بالاختيار
في الولايات المتحده واودوا ان اشكرك
الشباب في قال الولايات المتحده قيل لي ان
الصوت الشاب صوت بشكل كبير
وتطرق لي مواضيع ازمه المناخ
وعنف السلاح
والقرود الصليبيه
اتصلت به وهو يبلغ 25 من سنه وهو
عمره
في الكونغرس انا كنت ثاني اسخر همم شخص
تخرب في مجلس الشيوخ انا متاكد من ان لديه
سيره مهمه
وهمم
نخبون كانوا واضحين وعبر عن احباطهم وانا
افهم هذا الاحباط وانا افهم وانا السنوات
كانت صعبه بنسبه الى عدد كبير من الناس
لقد ورثنا امه خرج او كان فيها جائحه
واقتصاد يعاني من صعوبات عندما وصلت الى
سده الرئاسه وعملنا على اللقحات وعملنا
على
التعافي الاقتصاديه والاستثمارات لعله
بناء البناء التحتيه من طرق وجسور ومحطات
مياه وانترنت ونحن نبدا في هذا المسار
والامر واضح بالنسبه الى الناس في او سوف
يكون واضحا في شهر يناير وفبراير ومارس من
العام المقبل وبالتالي انا متحمس لرؤيه
تفاعل الشعب الامريكي وهناك استثمارات
تؤدي بالشركات
المليارات من الدولارات لبناء همم المصانع
هنا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا
سوف يؤدي الى استحداث 10,000 من الوظائف
وعددات كبيره من هذه الوظائف سوف
26,000$
الى شهاده جامعيه للحصول عليها نحن نتعامل
مع تضخم عالمي نتيجه لحرب بوتن في
اوكرانيا ونحن نتعامل مع هذا الموضوع بشكل
افضل من معظم الدول بنسبه الى اسعار
الوقود نحن ايضا عملنا على ضبط هذا الامر
باضافه الى اسعار الدواء
وتكلفه الطاقه بعد 20 شهر من العمل
الداؤوب الجائحه لا تصيطر على حياتنا
السياسات الاقتصاديه ادت الى استحداث 10
ملايين وظيفه جديده وهو رقم تاريخي وتراجع
البطاله الى ثلاثه فاصله سبعه بالمئه وهو
رقم تاريخي ب 50 عاما وايضا قمنا بخفض
العجز الفلاني
فاصل سبعه تريليون دولار 1.7 تريليون
دولار ولم تتمكن اي اداراه
هي التضخم نحن احرزنا التقدم على مستوى
البلاد ولكن يصعب على الناس ان يروا هذا
التقدم في حياته اليوميه ونتائج في حياتهم
اليوميه بناء على الخطوات التي اتخذناها
وتدبير التي قمنا بتنفيذها ولكن براي هذه
الخطوات كانت الصائبه للبلاد وللشعب
الامريكي اذا ماعيننا الارقام الاكثريه
الكبرى طبعا يمكننا ان نتحدث امامكم
يمكنكم ان تتابعوا معي هذه الارقام
الاكثريه من الشعب الامريكي دعمت عناصر
الاقتصاديه من اجنده من بنائه الطرق
والرسول والحد من ارتفاع اسعار الدواء
والتعامل مع ازمه المناخ وصولا الى التاكد
من ان الشركات الكبرى تدفع الضرائب بشكل
انا متاكد من ان هذه السياسات
ويجب ان نستمر بها كل المبادلات
تبدا من العملي على المصانع الجديده بناء
المصانع الجديده في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا ادى الى
700000 وظيفه جديد في هذا القطاع يمكننا
ان نكون مركز الصناعه في العالم نحن نصدر
السلعه والمنتجات وليس الوظائف الى بلدان
الاخرى في العالم الناس سوف يشاهدون هذه
التاثيرات الايجابيه على حياتهم اليوميه
ولكن انا افهم المخاوف التي يشعر بها عدد
الكبير من امريكا انا سوف استمر بالعمل
لتنفي
بالنسبه الى الشعب الامريكي ونحن وقعنا
اكثر من 200 11 قانون بدعم من الحزبين منذ
تواليه سده الرئاسه وعملنا على السلامه
اللي ضبط الاسلحه باضافته الى عشرات ال-
القوانين التي اثرت بشكل على حياتنا
وادعوني اقول ما يلي بغض النظر يعني نتيجه
النهائيه لهذه الانتخابات انا مستعد للعمل
مع زملائي الجمهوريين الشعب الامريكي
برايي اوضح انه يتوقع من الجمهوريين ان
يعملوا معي كذلك في السياسه الخارجيه اعمل
ان استمر بالعمل في مقاربه الحزبان في
مواجهه الاعتداء الروسي في اوكرانيا عندما
عدت من اجتماع مجموعه العشرين من
اندونيسيا دعوته
القيادات منه الحزبين الى البيت الابيض
لتناقشي في كيفيه العمل مع بعضنا البعض
فيما تبقى من هذا العام همم ما بعد ذلك
لتقدم الاقتصادي وانجاز التقدم الاقتصادي
للواتساب المتحده وانا منفتح على الافكار
اود ان اوضح لن ادعم اي مقترحات جمهوريه
سوف تؤدي الى حاله
الى ارتفاع اسعار الادويه نحن نعمل على
خفض هذه الاسعار وانا سوف استمر في تنفيذ
التزاماتنا بنسبه الى ازمه المناخ هذه
امور لن اقدم فيها التنازلات الناخبون لا
يودون ان
تقطع الضرائب المفروضه على الشركات الكبرى
وايضا ودوا ان اعمل على خفض الاسعار بنسبه
الى الطبقه العامله والمتوسطه واود ان
ابني الاقتصاد من القاعده الى اعلى الهرم
هذا ما اقوله دائما هذا ما يحقق النمو
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه عندما تكون الطبقه
الوسطى بحاله جيده هذا يؤدي الى التقدم
والاقتصادي والعمل على خفض العجز
يجب ان يخفض الضرائب على الطبقه العامله
والمتوسطه وليس الاثريه طبعا اذا ما اردتم
ان تكون
هذا جيد ولكن يجب ان تدفع الحصه العادله
من الضرائب
نتحدث عن 55 شركه حققت 55 مليار دولار
ولكنها لم تدفع ضريبه هذا غير عادل الان
يتعين عليها ان تدفع 15%
وانا سوف استمر
ولا اي شخص
يجني اقل من اربعين الف دولار سوف يرى
ارتفاعا في الضرائب الفيدراليه واود ان
اوضح انه ولا اي ظرف سوف يؤدي به الى دعم
مقترحات سنه جونسون وسنتر من فلوريدا
لتغييره همم الضمان الاجتماعي والرعايه
الصحيه ماديكار انا لن اوافق بذلك ايضا لن
اوافق على من على الاجهاض على مستوى
الولايات المتحده ولكن قد اتفقوا مع
الجمهوريين في مسائل اخرى لمصلحه الشعب
الامريكي اود ان اقتدم بالقول في هذا
الموسم الانتخابي اوضح الشعب الامريكي انه
لا يود ان تكون المعارك السياسيه مستمره
في كل يوم لقد سائمه من هذا الامر ويتعين
علينا ان نقوم بالكثير مستقبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعد للغايه ويجب ان
نبتعد عن هذه
المواجهات السياسيه المستمره وانا اكرر
ذلك للاشهر العشرين الماضي انا متفائل
للغايه من شان مستقبل الولايات المتحده
يجب ان ننظر نحو المستقبل ولنركز على
الماضي والمستقبل واعد نحن الامه الوحيده
في العالم التي خرجت من الازمه اقوى من ذي
قبل وانا اعني ما اقوله نحن اقوى مما كنا
عليه قبل ذلك انا متفائل للغايه بمستقبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه خصوصا عندما
اتحدث مع الشباب
ونحن نتحدث عن افضل الجير من حيث التعليم
في الولايات المتحده
واكثر جليه فعل ويشارك في الحياه العامه
بعد موسم من الحملات الانتخابيه انا اؤمن
اننا امه عظيمه وشعب عظيم ويجب
ان لا يراهن اي طرف ضد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما من شيء يتخطى قدراتنا الى ما
عملنا مع بعضنا البعض يجب ان نتذكر من نحن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما من شيء يتخطى
قدراتنا وانا مقتنع بقدره على تحقيق
المزيد حصلته على قائمه بعشره اشخاص كل
واحد منكم يفترض ان يطرح سؤالا واحدا سوف
ابدا بهذه القائمه مزيفه من السوشي
شكرا سيد الرئيس سؤلان
نحن لا نحاسبكم او لا نطلب منكم نفس
المعايير
اذا السؤال ذكرت ان لولا الشعب الامريكي
محبط
75% قال واننا نتجه بالاتجاه الخاطئ ما
الذي سوف تتغيره في السنوات المقبله لكي
يتغير راي الشعب بنسبه الى اتجاه البلاد
لن اغير شيء لان الشعب سوف يكتشف ما نقوم
به اصلا وهذا سوف يزيد الدعم الذي نحضر به
على سبيل المثال اسعار الادويه هل تود ان
ترى ارتفاعا باسعار الادويه او على سبيل
المثال ان اتوقف عن بناء الطرق والجسور
وتعزيز الانترنت الى اخره اعتقد في حقيقه
الامر ان المشكله هي ان
تشريعات الاساسيه بعضا منها بدعم من
الحسبين تتطلب وقتا لكي نعرف النتيجه على
سبيل ال الاستثمار بيئه تريليون دولار
ببنا تحتيه وهذا يتطلب وقتا كنت على
الهاتف
وهنئ همم
[موسيقى]
اشخاص من كاليفورنيا وايضا
العضل كونجرس الذي انتخب في بنسلفانيا
وقال هل يمكنك ان تتاكد من تامين همم خدمه
سكك حديد من نيويورك قلت نعم يمكننا ان
نقوم بذلك هذا سوف يسهل علينا من خلال
التخفيف من عدد السيارات على الطرق
واصلا هناك قانون صوتنا عليه بالنسبه الى
هذا الموضوع والامر السيئان بالنسبه الى
امر اخر تحدثت في خلال الحمله اننا سوف
نحد من الدفاع ومن تكلفه الانساني
وهذا سوف يدخل حيز التنفيذ العام المقبل
وبالتالي هناك سلسله من الامور التي سوف
تظهر الامر سيان بنسبه الى المواضيع
البيئيه نحن بحاجه الى وقت لكي نرى
التاثير وبالتالي لن يغير هناك بعض الامور
التي اود ان اعدلها على سبي مثال قمنا
بتمريره تشريعا بدعم من الحزبين بشان ضبطي
السلاح ولكن انا اود ان
امنع ال- اا الرشاشات
القتاليه وبالتالي انا سوف استمر بالعمل
على التزامات وانا اقر وافهم المخاوف بشان
ما اقوله اولا انا همم اعبر عن التزام
متجدد
بانزاهه وبالشرف في هذا البلد
والحوار يصبح طبيعيا بشكل اكبر
كيف لي ان اعبر عن ذلك اذا يصبح لبقا بشكل
اكبر واود ان ابني البلاد من الاسفل الى
الاعلى وليس من الاعلى الى الاسفل انا
سئمت من هذه الطريقه السابقه النقطه
الثالثه اعرف انها صعبه ولكن افضل قصار
جهد لاعاده توحيد البلاد طبعا لا يمكننا
ان نستمر بالقول اننا قياديون في مجال
الديمقراطيه في العالم اذا ما لم نعمل على
هذا الامر وبالتالي لن نغير
السؤال اخر روسيا
كريستيانو
اخرصون والناس يعتقدون انها نقطه تقاطع في
النزاعال برايك اوكرانيا لديها ميختون
اوراق ضغط للمفاوضات مع موسكو اولا ااا
ارى انه من المثير الاهتمام انهم انتظروا
حتى نهايه الانتخابات لكي يعبر عن هذه
الفكره وكنا نعرف انهم سوف يقومون بذلك
منذ فتره وهذا ايضا يعني ان الجيش الروسي
يعاني مشاكل متعدده ثانيا ما اذا كان هذا
الامر سوف يؤدي بالحد الادنى الى
بكالوري
المواقع في
فتره الشتاء ويتعاون علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
ما اذا كانت اوكرانيا على جاهزيه لتقديم
التنازلات انا سوف اذهب الى مؤتمر الدول
العشرين قيل لي ان الرئيس
متعددين وسوف ننظر في الخطوات المقبله
نانسي نانسي
شكرا سيد الرئيس لدي بضعه اسئله
اولا كيفن مكارث يقال انه من الواضح اننا
سوف نستعيد مجلس النواب هل هو على حق
بناءا على ما نعرفه حتى اللحظه الراهنه
لقد خسرنا عدد قليلا من المقاعد بشكل مؤكد
وهناك احتمال
بامكانيه الحفاظ على المجلس النواب ولكن
نتيجه متقاربه في نضال كسبنا المقاعد
الثلاثه التي كان هناك تنافس عليه وتحدثت
مع المرشحين كسبنا هذه المقاعد وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن امور المتغيره لكن النتيجه
متقاربه للغايه هلا وصفت علاقتك
ما رايك
صدق الله العظيم انه زعيم الجمهوري ولم
احضر بفرصه الحديث معه بشكل كبير سوف
اتحدث معه على الارجح لاحقا اليوم بنسبه
الى الاجنده التشريعيه عندما كنت نائما
للرئيس
اصطدمت الاجنده بحائط بعد سيطره
الجمهوريين على مجلس النواب وستمر
لرئاسه اوباما هل هناك طريقه لكي تمنع ان
يحصل نفس الشيء في هذه المره نعم
لان النتيجه سوف تكون متقاربه اكثر اذا ما
حققوا لاغلبيه طبعا انا لا اود ان انتقد
اي جهات قدمت التوقعات همم تحدثت عن مدن
احمر خساره 50 مقعدا ولكن نعرف ان هذا لن
يحصل وبالتالي هناك دائما ما يكفي من
اشخاص في الفريقين سواء كنا نتحدث في
الجانب الجمهوري او الجانب الديمقرا اذا
دائما هناك اشخاص يمكن ان يؤمنوا التواصل
للتقدم ولكن على سبيل المثال
طبعا انا لا اتوقع ان تجيب عن هذا السؤال
ولكن هل برايك على سبيل المثال
السنتر جونسون سوف
يقطع
الضمان الاجتماعي
والرعايه الصحيه اذن وما هو عدد
الجمهوريين الذين سوف يصوت لصالح اذا ما
قام بذلك سؤالي الاخير
الجمهوريون كانوا واضحين اذا ما سيطروا
على مجلس النواب يودون ان يطلق سلسل من
التشريعات في ال- اا من التحقيقات عفوا في
الطريقه الخروج من افغانستان والحدود وهمم
الوزارات المختلفه
وانت شخصيا وابنك بالتالي ما هي رساله
الرئيس
لاولائك الذين ان يحققوا
ابنك واا بك شخصيا اعتقد ان الشعب
الامريكي يود ان نمضي قدما لنفسه اذا
الامور المختلفه
سمعته باخبار لا اعرف مدى دقه الاخبار
تقول ان الجمهوريين هو رئيس الصادق قال كم
من مره سوف تعزل
اجراءات المحاكمه بهدفيه اعتقد ان الشعب
الامريكي سوف يرى حقيقه هذا الامر وكانه
مشهد كوميدي في حقيقه الامر ولكن لا
يمكنني ان اتحكم بما سوف يقومون به انا جل
ما يمكنني ان اقوم به وان احسن حياه الشعب
الامريكي فيلم سينان
شكرا سيد رئيس لدي 37 سؤال
اذا الشهر الماضي قلت العالم ينظر نحو هذه
الانتخابات
الاشرار والاخيار كذلك في نفس اللحظه
الرئيس السابق ينظر في امكانيه ترشحه في
العام 2024 ماذا بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
اولا
القاده في العالم يعرفون اننا نبلي بلا ان
افضل من دول العالم المختلفه طبعا هناك
مشاكل ولكن الاقتصاد الامريكيه ينمو في
التقرير الاخير نتحدث عن اثنين فاصله سته
بالمئه نحن نستحدث الوظائف
في بلدان اخرى وبناء على الاتصالات التي
اقوم بها واللقاءات مع قاده الدول هم
يتطلعون نحو الولايات المتحده ويطرحون
الاسئله كيف تقومون بذلك وكيف لنا ان نقوم
بالمثل اعتقد اذا ان اكثر هي الزملاء
خصوصا على مستوى الناتو واتحاد الاوروبي
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه هي ودون ان
يتعاونوا لكي نساعد بعضنا بعضا ما هو
السؤال الاخر
عن
انتقال
باتجاه
وضعه حدا اللي ما سبق
وتغير طريقه التخاطب هل برايك الانتخابات
هي همم العمل المغير لا اعتقد ان
التابعيه او الذين يدعون ماذا من ضمن
الجمهوريه سوف يغيرون في اسلوبهم ولكن
اعتقد ان بالنسبه الى اكثريه
الجمهوريين ولو اننا نختلف معهم ولكن همم
هناك احترام متبادل
اا وجدت الاختلافات في مسائل متعدده ان
اعمل او عملت معهم في مجلس الشيوخ وفي
مجلس النواب وهم همم صادقون
ويعبرون عن افكارهم ولو كانت مختلفه
واعتقد بالتالي ان همم باقي الدول وانتم
تغطون هذه الاخبار الدول العالم اعتقد ان
افضل طريقه يمكن ان نعبر عن هذه الفكره من
خلالها بتكرار ما قلته في السابق
جي 7
للدول الصناعيه السابعه اذا نتحدث عن اكبر
سبع ديمقراطيات عندما ذهبت الى الاجتماع
في فبراير بعد حفل التنصيب جلست على
الطاوله المستديره مع القاده الست من
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكندا الى اخره وقلت الولايات المتحده قد
اعادت احدهم طرح السؤال حتى متى كان سؤالا
صريحا حتى متى
[موسيقى]
الشخص الاخر
اذا ما على سبيل المثال همم
استيقظنا اليوم يوم غد في انجلترا وشاهدنا
الالاف يقتحمون برلمان البريطانيه وادى
ذلك الى وفاه شرطيين عدد من الجرحه
وحاولوا ان يوقفوا التنصيف حفله تنصيب
طبعا الوضع يختلف اذا قال لي ما رايك
وسؤالي لكم همم ولا اتوقع اجابه ما رايكم
الراي ان الديمقراطيه على المحك هناك
مشكله اذا ما حصل ذلك وبالتالي هذه هي
الطريقه التي كان ينظر الناس من خلالها
الينا متى سيتوقف ذلك ما من شيئا مماثل
حصل منذ الحرب الاهليه لا اود ان ابالغ
ولكن هذه هي الحقيقه وبالتالي ما وجدته هو
انهم ارادوا ان يعرف ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مستقره هل نحن نفس الديمقراطيه
التي لطالما كنا عليها
العالم يتطلع الينا نحن لسنا دائما على حق
هذا لا اعني ذلك ولكن على سبيل المثال اذا
انسحبت الولايات المتحده يوم غد من العالم
امورا كثيره سوف تتغير في العالم امورا
كثيره وبالتالي يودون ان يعرفوا اننا لا
نزال الديمقراطيه المنفتحه ولدينا حكم
القانون والمؤسسات المهمه وهذا هو الاطار
السؤال هو هل عدنا الى مكان نقدا فيه
قرارات المحاكم والكونغرس والحكومه الى
اخره
اذا بالنسبه الى هذه الاسئله هي مرتبطه
بالرئيس السابق الذي يشارك على اطلاقه
حمله جديده وبالتالي كيف لك ان تطمئن
هؤلاء بان الرئيس السابق لن يعود والحركه
السياسيه التي تتبع الرئيس السابق ولكن لا
تزال قويه حقا لا تزال قويه
ان نثبت لهم انه لن يتمكن من الوصول الى
سده الرئاسه في حال قام بحمله بالفعل اذا
نوده
لن يكون رئيس الجديد مجددا
شكرا
النتائج بالنسبه الى ترشحك انت للانتخابات
المقبله وما هي المده الزمنيه لنظري بهذا
الاحتمال اولا جل وانا زوجتي جل هنا
وهمم تحظى بشعبيه اكبر مني في الحزب
الديمقراطي في الحقيقه اذا بشكل
مجددا وبغض النظر عن نتيجه
الانتخابات هذه
ويوان
حقيقه اننا ربحنا طبعا انا لم اكن
المشاركه انا ولكن الحزب الديمقراطي قبل
بدا افضل مما توقعه الجميع بالمقارنه مع
كل
العهود منذ جون كندي اذا هذا يؤدي الى
الاطمئنان بان
اتباع المانجا على
مفاصل الحكم والى اخره وبالتالي بالنسبه
الى ترشحي
نيه هي ان اترشح مجددا ولكن طبعا انا همم
احترم قرار العائله ولكن يتعين علينا ان
نتناقش بشان هذا الموضوع وانا لا اود ان
استعجل لاتخاد القرار اليوم او يوم غد
النظري عن افعال الرئيس السابق
السنه او السنه المقبله
امل ان جيل وانا سوف نحظى ببعض الوقت لكي
همم نهرب قليلا في اجازه بين عيد الميلاد
وعيد الشكر واعتقد ان العام المقبل سوف
نتخذ هذا القرار ولكن خطته هي تقضي بان
اقوم بذلك اعتذر اذا
كان
الرئيس
الى سجن لتسع سنوات في روسيا هل لديك
تحديث عن وضعها وحالتها وهل هناك مفاوضات
مع روسيا لاطلاقيها
وبانجاتي
انخرطنا بشكل
دوري في
حديثا وطبعا انا كنت اتابع اوضاعها
واملي الان وقد انتهت الانتخابات السيد
بوتن سوف يكون على استعدادا لكي يتناقش
معنا بشان تبادل السجناء اذا النيه تقضي
بان تعود الى
بلادها
وقمنا باجراء سلسله من المحادثات
والان وقد انتهت الانتخابات تامل ان يكون
هناك نيه اللي كان يتفاوض بهذا الشان بشكل
محدد شكرا اذا المسؤوله الصحفيه قالت ان
الحكومه تتابع هذا الموضوع ولكن طرح حتى
طرقا بديله مع الروس هلا قلت لنا ما هي
الطرق البديله بالنسبه الى الاستجابه
الروس يمكنني ان اجيب عن السؤال ولكن لن
اجيب عن السؤال هذا ليس همم ليس من الحكمه
ان نقوم بذلك
ولكن يمكنني ان اقول لك انني عازما بان
تعود الى بلادها هي واخرين بشكل امن
اعتذر
اذا المره الماضيه
السيد رئيس لديه سلسله من الاسئله حول
مسائل متعدده المحكمه العليا
قبول في الجامعات ما هي الخطاب بالنسبه
الى هذا الموضوع هناك محل للين يتحدثون عن
تبعات اساسيه يمكن ان تؤثر على القرار
السابق اذا اولا طلبته من وزاره العدل ان
تدافع عن السياسه الحاليه امام المحكمه
العليا طبعا انا لا اعتقد ان المحكمه
العليا سوف تنقد القرار السابق انا لا ارى
ذلك ولكن
همم تقديمي الدف من قبل اداراتنا امام
المحكمه العليا
وعرض ذلك
اثنان هناك سلسله من الامور التي يمكن ان
نقوم بها نحن نتحدث عن
اااه
مواطن الامريكي
اسيوي امريكي
ونحن نتحدث عن
يمكننا ان نقوم به بالكثير لكي نتاكد من
الوصول الى همم خدماته تعليم جيده بشكل
عام بدء التعليم بشكل رسمي في المدارس عند
سن
الثالثه وكل الدراسات تثبت بان هذا
الموضوع سوف يساعد الطلاب بغض النظر عن
خلفياتها
اعتقد ايضا ان هو يتعين علينا ان نتاكد من
قدرنا على تامين سنتين تعليمتين بعد ذلك
هو ايضا
نحن في وضع يدفعني الى ضروره العمل على
المجالي
التاكد من مساعدتي الخاص الاقل حظوه لكي
يدخل الى المدارس طبعا نحن نعرف ان تكلفه
الدخول الى الجامعات تضاعفت اربعه اضعاف
والان نتحدث عن ارتفاعا كبير وبالتالي اود
ان اعمل على موضوع المنح
انا لدي امل
بامكانياتي تحقيق تقدم وطبعا همم فريق همم
لديه خطه بهذا الخصوص
بنسبه الى مساله
التضخم كان هناك دراسه بنسبه الى الناخبين
من ذوي البشره السوداء تحدثوا وقالوا ان
تضخم هو الاولويات في السنتين المقبلتين
ما هي الخطه التي سوف تغير هذا المسار
اولا
البطاله
لذوي البشره السوداء
خفضت
بالنصف وهناك شركات
اللي اشخاص من اصول افريقيه همم
بشكل متزايد وايضا هناك امكانيه شراء
المنازل لهؤلاء بشكل اكبر وانا شخصيا نحن
من الطبقه الوسطى والدي همم كان يصروا على
ضروره منزل وهو امرا اساسي بالنسبه الى
طبقه الوسطى ولكن ما لا يمكنني ان اقوم به
هو انه لا يمكنني ان
اؤكد ان سوف نتخلص من التضخم ولكن نحن
قمنا بخفض سعر الوقود بحوالي دولار 20 سنه
للجالون واعتقدوا ان شركات النفط لا تساعد
الولايات المتحده ست شركات حققت اكثر من
100 مليار دولار في الربع الاخير ارباح
مئه مليار دولار في الماضي
له قاموا بامور بشكل مختلف لو استثمر
بمحطاتي التكرير او ايضا بيع النفط باسعار
اقل لكي تصل الى محطات الوقود هذا يؤدي
طبعا الى خفض جالون الوقود اذن هناك سلسله
من الامور التي يمكن ان نقوم بها وهي صعبه
ولكننا سوف نستمر بالدفع قدما لكي نفتحها
وايضا نقطه اخرى تحدث فرقا كبيرا ما هي
التكلفه التي تدفعها العائله او الاسره
وبيبقى في ذلك الاسر بدوي البشر السوداء
نتحدث عن تكلفه الدواء هذا امرا اساسي انا
عارف ان عددا كبيرا من الناس بحاجه الى
الانسولين لمرض او دا السكر اذا نحن سوف
نخفض الى 35 دولار عن معدل 400 دولار
والدي كان يتحدث عن هذا الموضوع بطريقه
مختلفه في نهايه الشهر هناك امور يتعيون
علينا ان ندفع القرض السكن
والطعام والوقود هل لديك ما يكفي من
الاموال لكي تقوم بذلك وبعد القيام بذلك
هل لديك ما لم تدخره
وخصوصا بنسبه الى الفقراء وبالنسبه الى
الاسر المداوي للبشره السوداء في الولايات
المتحده نحن نعمله على تشريعات سوف تؤثر
ايجابيا على هؤلاء بشكل شهري لكي ينخفض
معدل التضخم بنسبه اليه
وتكلفه المعيشه سوف تنخفض انا متفائلا
بانه باستطاعاتنا ان همم نحقق الاموال
بشكل جيد نحن لم نقترب من ركود اقتصادي
ولكن يمكن انا مقتنع انه باستطاعتنا ان
نخفض الاسعار بشكل تدريجي كي لا ندخل في
الركود من اجل ضبط التضخم
سؤال اخير الى موضوع الانسانيه
الى التشريعات
والاوامر التنفيذيه همم هي لا تدخل حيز
همم او الحيض الانساني وهناك خطابات
ناريه في هذه الفتره ما الذي ياتي في
المستقبل
بتستاهل جزء مما تتطلبه القياده وامل ان
اكون هذا النوع من
القاده
يقضي بان يفهم الشعب المشاكل الوارد كان
يقول انا لا اتوقع ان الحكومه تحل مشاكل
ولكن اتوقع من الحكومه ان تفهم ما هي
مشاكل وشاني عدد كبير منكم اذا
واجهنا مشاكل
وظروف صعبه
حبيبي انا شخصيا
حضيته او كنت محظوظا بان كان لدي عائله
ساعدتني
بالمضيق قدما كان معاناه طبعا بسبب الحادث
الذي ادى الى مقتل لي
زوجتي الاولى وايضا انا افهم هذا
الالم وعندما جل وانا خسرنا الضوء بعد
عودته من العراق وبعد معاناته من المرض
بسبب تلوث الهواء جراء حرق كل النفايات
السامه
واصابته بمرض نحن نفهم ما هي همم خساره
اعضاء
ولكننا كنا محظوظين نحن عملنا سويا هو نحن
عائله قويه مع شقيقاتي واشقائي اذن
يجب ان نتاكد من وجودي اشخاص يساعدون سواء
كانوا من المعالجين النفسيين او الاطباء
او العاملين الاجتماعيين لكي يساعدوا لكي
يمدوا اليد لهؤلاء ويمكننا ان نقوم
بالكثير لهذه العائلات من خلال
دعم الاطفال
هناك الكثير الذي يمكن ان نقوم به في هذا
المجال التعاطف ليس فقط مجرد كلام هناك
اهميه التواصل مع الناس الذين نفحمهم
وطبعا هناك اشخاص لا يفهمون هذا الالم
ولكن النقطه الاساسيه هي ان يعرف الجميع
اننا
نود ان ان نساعد
هناك نقطه تعريفها هناك حاجه الى
الرعايه الصحيه
النفسيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كان هناك مليون
ثلاثه ملايين او اربعه ملايين شخص عندما
حصلوا على اللقاح ولكن
ما الذي حصل
في نفس الوقت خسرنا اكثر من مليون
مواطن ومواطنه
بنسبه الى هؤلاء
لكل واحد منهم على الاقل او كمعدل تسعه
اشخاص من
الاقارب وبالتالي الوقت كان عميقا فكروا
بكل اطفالكم واحفادكم الذين لم يصلوا الى
سنين التخرج وحفله التخرج من المدرسه من
الجامعه كل هذه الامور التي ناخذها هكذا
بالمجان وتاثيرها هذا الامر على نفسيتها
وبالتالي التعاطف والشعور مع الاخرين يقضي
بمعرفه حاجه الاخرين وتحقيق وتلبيه هذه
الحاجه عددا كبيرا من الناس ايضا من
الجمهوريين يحاولون ان يقوموا بذلك نحن
نعرف ان لدي مشكله عذرا
هذه الاسئله العشر تمر بسرعه في حقيقه
الامر
يتعين علي ان اتحدث الى القضاء الجمهوريين
جنين
شكرا السيد الرئيس السؤال اولا بالعوده
الى زيارتك الى اسيا عند لقائك بالرئيس
هل سوف تقول له بان الولايات المتحده
تدافع عن تايوان بشكل عسكري في حاله
الحاجه وهل تقدم تنازلات انا لست مستعدا
لتقديم اي تنازلات جوهريه لانه منذ
البدايه لقد امضيته همم حوالي 60 او 70
ساعه معه عندما كنت نائما للرئيس الرئيس
اوباما كان يعرف ليس باستطيع ان يمضي كل
هذا الوقت وبالتالي انا زرته الصين وهو
كان في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قلت له
انا اود ان ارى منى
عندما اتحدث اليه اود ان نرسم
صوت الحمراء بالنسبه الى كيلينا بنسبه
اليها ما هي المصالح
الوطنيه الاساسيه
للصين وبالنسبه اليه للولايات المتحده
نتاكد من عدم تظهر بها واذا ما كانت
متضاربه يجب ان نعمل على ذلك ان عقيده
تايوان لم تتغير منذ البدايه منذ بدايه
وانا متاكد من اننا سوف نتناقش
بموضوع تايوان بالاضافه الى سلسله من
الامور الاخرى التجاره العادله
[موسيقى]
والعلاقات
المرتبطه
بعلاقه الصين بدول اخرى في المنطقه
اذا هناك الكثير من الامور لكي نتناقش بها
السؤال الاخر
اذا بنسبه الى ما اذا كنت سوف تقول له انك
تلتزم بدفايه عن تايوان سوف اتحدث اليه
حول هذا الموضوع
السيد الرئيس هل الى الماسك هو تهديد
للامن القومي الامريكي الولايات المتحده
بكل الادوات التي لديكم هل يجب ان تحقق
بالاستحواذ على تويتر مع الحكومات بما في
ذلك السعوديه
ايمان
التقنيه مع بلدان اخرى
اذن يجب ان ينظر فيها
ماذا كان يقوم باي امر غير
مناسب انا لا اقول ذلك ولكن
ارى انه من الجيد ان ينظر بهذا الامر وهذا
كل ما اود ان اقوله بهذا الشان هناك
نشرب هذا رن ايفون
ان اتحدث اليك بنسبه الى العمل مع
الجمهوريين الزعيم كارثي قال مجددا انه
ليس على استعداد لاعطاء الشكل على بياض
بنسبه الى اوكرانيا ولكنك انت عبرت عن
تفائلك بالنسبه الى استمرار تمويل
اوكرانيا والسياسات تجاهها اوكرانيا لماذا
يجب ان يثق الشعب اوكرانيا بهذه التعهدات
بالنظر الى تعليقات السيد مكه
وقلت انك لن تقوم باي شيء بشكل مختلف اذا
ما سيطر الجمهوريون على مجلس النواب الا
يتعين عليك ان تعيد ضبط السياسات
معنيته هو انني لن اغير السياسات التي مرت
اذا هو التي تم الموافقه عليها اذا ما كان
هناك مقترح لا اوافق عليه لدي قلم يمكنني
ان استخدم حق الفيتو اذا
بنسبه الى موضوع البنى التحتيه وتمويل
التحتيه وموضوع المناخ الى اخره يتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع
اعتقدوا ان هناك
ضغوط متزايده من قبل الشعب الامريكي على
الحزبين
تو وركعت الشمس
الاختلافات في وجهه النظر
وعدم التركيز على مصلحه الحزب او المصلحه
الشخصيه وبالتالي يتعين علينا ان ننتظر
لنرى تشكيله مجلس النواب الجديده ولكن امل
ان كبن وانا باستطاعاتنا ان نتوصل الى
اسلوب عمل او طريقه عمل
هل سوف يستمر الدعم لاوكرانيا بشكل غير
منقطع هذا ما اتوقعه بالمناسبه لا نعطي
شكا على بياض لاوكرانيا طلبه اوكرانيا
امورا متعدده ولكننا لم نقدمها على المثال
الطائرات الامريكيه
للضمان اجواء اوكرانيا اوكرانيا قلت لا لن
ندخل في حرب عالميه ثالثه من خلال
الاصطدام بطائرات الروسيه بشكل مباشر قلت
له ولكن
تدافع عن نفسها على سبيل المثال بالاضافه
الى المعدات الاخرى اذن هناك صواريخ وهناك
همم صواريخ لم نعطيها لاكرانيا كي لا تصل
الى الاراضي الروسيه
اذا نود في هذه العلاقه ان نتاكد من قدره
اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن نفسها
وايضا لصدي افظع اعتداء منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه من قبل بوتن والذي
استهدف اوكرانيا
لمكارسي اكثريه على مستوى الحزب الجمهوري
ارادت ال تخفض الدعم لاوكرانيا
طبعا هناك الكثير من الاهتمام بنسبه الى
انتخابات 2024
ثلثاء الشعب الامريكي يقول يتعين عليك ان
لا تترشح مجددا ما رسالتك وكيف يؤثر ذلك
على قرارك هذا لا يؤثر على قراري ما هي
رسالتك
شهدنا الحكم
النصر الكبير
شكرا سيد الرئيس سؤال ولكن قبل ذلك اود ان
اعقب على شيئا تفضلت به اذا
قلت يجب ان ننتظر لنرى ما اذا كانت
الحكومه الاوكرانيه على استعداد لتقديم
التنازلات مع الروسيا في الماضي قيل لنا
ان روسيا يتعين عليها ان تخرج بشكل كامل
من اوكرانيا والعوده الى خطي الى قبل
الرابعه والعشرين من شوبات فبراير ماذا
بالنسبه الى هذه التنازلات هذا يعود الى
الاوكرانيين ما من شيء يقرر عن اوكرانيا
من دوني مشاركه اوكرانيا
اذا لقد طرحت السؤال وهذه اجابه اذا
اعتقد ان السياق هو
اذا ما اذا كانوا سوف
ينسحبوا ينسحبونه من خرسان من مدينه خرسون
ويعذرون النهر نحو الشرق نتحدث هنا على
القوات الروسيه قلت في هذا السياق ان
القرار يجب ان يتخذ بالنسبه الى فصل
الشتاء حول ما اذا كان سوف يقدم سوف
يقدمون التنازلات ام لا اعرف ما هي
القرارات ولكن لن نملى عليهم اي شيء
بنسبه الى لقاء لقاء بالرئيس شيء
وفقا لتقديرات البنتاجون هناك رفع
لالف
وصولا لالف سلاح نووي من قبلهم و هو رقم
قياسيه بنسبه الى العقود الماضيه
اذا تتذكر كيف لم توافق عندما تحدثت عن
هذا الموضوع في السابق كلا انا انا انا
هذا من المثير للاهتمام
وعايزين
متطرف في رايه ولكن الان انت تقر بي ان
رايي كان صائما
هل ترى
انه تتحدث مع الرئيس تشي بنسبه الى
انتشاري السلاح
كلا لا اعتقد ان هناك احترام كبير من قبل
الصين لروسيا اذا
ابن سوريا الى هذا تحالف ارى ان هناك
مسافه وضعتها الصين بينها وبين روسيا
بالنسبه الى
ان نرى ما اذا كان
يودوا ان يستمر
بالمضيق قدما بالتزامه بان تكون الصين
لديها اقوى جيش في العالم اقوى اقتصاد في
العالم هو لا يزال بعيدا عن تحقيق هذين
الهدفين ولكن بنسبه الى الاسلحه النوويه
والمواقع ونفاذ هذا محمد شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا